this is all too
metaphysical for me um i want to get
physical
really one definition of the world is
the physical nature of the planet
the first thing that donald trump says
he will do
is abandon the climate change accord but
you only came into being last week
sort of amazing to me that actually if
we're talking about saving the world
the first thing is actually doing
something about
arresting the the appallingly
threatening atrocity of climate change
the fact that donald trump it's not a
problem for him
actually that he could and someone who
by the way has a large house in florida
where slimy inundation is already
lapping at the foundations can do this
means that actually reason is dead the
entirety of the election campaign
was a victory of lies falsehood
uh irrationality over reason so the
first thing we have to ask ourselves is
how do we actually develop a form of
communication which is not
intellectual exactly i'm so interested
in your
in your out brilliantly outrageous
interpolation
how do we actually how do we actually
make reason
entertaining how do we speak how many
millennials are there out there in the
darkness
actually if you put up your hands i
couldn't see you anyway right
okay okay not enough of you
showed up to vote in minnesota and
arizona
and and
so this is you know if we start with the
basic question of how to save the planet
earth then we get to the question of how
do we find a language that
deals with the entertainment of unreason
i'm not talking dr pangloss here i'm
just saying the possibility of affecting
a political decision
by distinguishing lies from truth that's
you know
kind of ground zero of the enlightenment
really things follow from that
that has been essentially confounded it
didn't matter
that you know when donald trump was
caught out of the lie he'd
as we say in america double down on the
lie
that seems to be something the marquis
era condor say could probably not have
anticipated
you